c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir ce rapport de l'ONU sur
l'implication du Rwanda dans le conflit
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo dans ce document qui n'a pas
encore été officiellement publié qu'il y
a lui est accusé d'avoir fourni des
armes des uniformes et des munitions au
rebelles du M23 les détails avec notre
correspondante à Kinshasa dans ce
journal La Côte d'Ivoire qui espère la
libération de ces 46 détenus au Mali
garantis soldats détenus au Mali une
délégation ivoirienne est arrivée à
Bamako ce jeudi alors que la CEDEAO a
exigé leur libération avant le premier
janvier où en sont les discussions nous
poserons la question à Serge Daniel
notre confrère des récits
et à la fin de ce journal nous irons au
Nigéria ou une célèbre plasticienne
française a voulu rendre hommage au
chibok girls ces jeunes filles
kidnappées par beaucoup Aram en 2014 108
d'entre elles sont toujours captives
l'artiste prune nourrit à superviser la
réalisation de 108 têtes en terre cuite
représentant ces jeunes filles pour
lutter contre l'oubli reportage à suivre
[Musique]
rien de nouveau dans ce rapport de l'ONU
il a fuité et il n'a pas encore été
officiellement publié dans ce document
des experts établissent l'implication du
Rwanda dans le conflit qui sévit dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo qui Gally est accusé d'apporter un
soutien au rebelle du M23 ce n'est pas
la première fois le Rwanda a plusieurs
reprises rejetées ses accusations pour
le moment pas de réaction du côté
rwandais mais la République démocratique
du Congo mais pour la République
démocratique du Congo ce rapport est
très attendue notre correspondant à
Kinshasa aurélie bazarra kibangula a pu
consulter le rapport elle nous en livre
ses détails écoutez
le Rwanda fournit des armes des
munitions et des uniformes aux rebelles
du M23 pour mener des opérations
militaires sur le territoire congolais
c'est ce qu'affirme des experts des
Nations unies dans un nouveau rapport
qui n'est pas encore publié mais que
nous avons pu consulter alors ce rapport
de plus de 200 pages documents des
attaques délocalités menées par le M23
dans la province du Nord qui vous et les
experts onusiens disent avoir collecté
des preuves substantielles démontrant
l’intervention directe des forces
rwandaises en RDC alors ses preuves se
sont des témoignages des habitants des
localités attaquées et de la société
civile sur place mais aussi des photos
prises sur place et par drone alors sur
ces photos on peut voir des munitions
utilisées par l'armée rwandaise et
récupérer par les forces armées
congolaises mais aussi des hommes
portant des uniformes et du matériel
connu pour être utilisé par les forces
rwandaises le rapport documente des
faits qui se leurs produits entre
novembre 2021 et octobre 2022 alors
c'est un rapport très attendu ici à
Kinshasa car les autorités dénoncées
depuis plusieurs mois le soutien
rwandais au rebelles du M23 des
accusations qui jusque là avait du mal à
être entendu des sources politiques en
coulisses dénoncées l'inaction de la
communauté internationale désormais le
Rwanda est aussi accusé par les
États-Unis et plusieurs pays européens
de soutenir les rebelles du M23 malgré
tout Kigali continue de nier et accuse à
son tour Kinshasa d'instrumentaliser un
conflit à des fins politiques
les 46 soldats ivoiriens détenus au Mali
depuis juillet vont-ils être libérés
prochainement en tout cas les
négociations se poursuivent une
délégation officielle ivoirienne et est
arrivée ce jeudi à Bamako et là CEDEAO
maintient la pression les chefs d'Etat
West africains ont exigé leur libération
avant le premier janvier pour en parler
nous retrouvons Serge Daniel journaliste
à RFI bonsoir Serge ou en sont les
discussions est-ce que les familles
ivoiriennes des soldats peuvent espérer
les revoir bientôt
alors en tout cas on peut qu'on peut
parler de décrispation dans ce dossier
entre les deux pays ici au Mali lors de
la rencontre à Bamako en présence du
médiateur togolais les deux parties ont
accepté de signer un document on n'a pas
encore tous les détails mais d'après les
informations se dit document signé
renforce des relations entre le Mali et
la Côte d'Ivoire et il devrait permettre
également d'obtenir une issue heureuse
dans le dossier des 46 militaires
ivoiriens détenus depuis 5 mois à Bamako
d'ailleurs juste important ce jeudi le
gouvernement malien a autorisé la
délégation ivoirienne conduite par le
ministre des tâches chargé de la défense
a rencontré les militaires ils se
portent plutôt bien alors maintenant
passeront-ils les fêtes de fin d'année
en famille seront-ils libérés une source
très au fait du dossier reste optimiste
mais rappelle quand même qu'il y a des
obstacles administratifs voies
judiciaire à lever par exemple le
dossier ayant été entre-temps
judiciarisé et notre interlocuteur
d'ajouter avec un brin d'humour
impossible et cependant ni malien ni
ivoirien merci beaucoup Serge Daniel
journalier RFI merci pour toutes ces
précisions et puis concernant le malice
sachez que la que la quasi pardon
totalité des groupes armées maliens
signataires d'un important accord de
paix au Mali en 2015 dont Alex rébellion
touareg suspendu jeudi leur
participation à cet accord dit d'Alger
ces groupes ont tous pointé du doigt
l'absence persistant de volonté
politique je cite de la jante au pouvoir
pour la mise en œuvre de cet accord
l'audience est ouverte aujourd'hui de
dans une ambiance assez pesante ça a
commencé avec une minute de silence pour
les 19 personnes tuées dans cette
attaque ils ont cité le nom de toutes
les personnes qui ont donc été qui ont
perdu la vie ce jour-là ou en tout cas
toutes celles qui ont pu être
identifiées hier le procureur a demandé
à ce que a requis la prison à perpétuité
pour les quatre accusés ainsi que pour
les six cerveaux de l'attaque qui ne
sont pas présents à cette audience
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas été présents
depuis les trois dernières semaines et
le l'avocat de la défense a justement
demandé à ce que les juges ne confondent
pas ce qu'ils ont appelé la justice avec
de la vengeance ils ont justement basé
leurs défenses sur l'idée que tous ne
devraient pas avoir la même sentence que
certains qui sont considérés comme les
petites mains de cette attaque les
personnes qui auraient conduit les
attaquants qui auraient logé les
attaquants et qui auraient organisé les
armes pour cette attaque ne devrait pas
d'après l'avocat de la défense recevoir
toujours la même peine que les cerveaux
de l'attaque comme on les appelle
on part à présent au Burkina Faso vous
le savez la crise sécurité a des
conséquences directes sur le commerce
les attaques terroristes freinent
l'arrivée des investisseurs et selon de
nombreux spécialistes elles réduisent le
taux de croissance du pays une situation
qui pénalise surtout les commerçants
engenomeno est allé à leur rencontre
reportage
du riz local burkinabè prêt pour
livraison la marchandise doit être
acheminée vers Dory au Sahel dans la
région du nord-est
Ousmane Maïga le chauffeur est un
habitué du trajet depuis que les
terroristes ont envahi ces zones de
service sa clientèle à drastiquement
baissé la clientèle de commander
maintenant beaucoup
il peut perdre parce que on peut croiser
le camion brûlé on ne sait pas quelque
chose qui peut arriver voilà il peut
perdre la caméra aussi donc tout est
possible tout est là-bas on a tellement
peur parce que dès que on quitte Kaya
pour rentrer à Dory vraiment on a peur
on sait pas que ceux qui peut nous
arrive avant l'arrivée du terrorisme
Ousmane pouvait effectuer 8 livraisons
de marchandises par mois mais depuis
2015 il arrive à boucler à peine 4
livraisons selon le vice-président de la
Chambre du Commerce burkinabè cette
situation affecte également les échanges
intra régionaux naturellement vous savez
que les frontières maintenant qui sont
difficilement praticables notamment au
niveau de l'est donc ce qui est
contraint
les acteurs de la chaîne logistique
notamment transporteur et logiciel de
même si lorsqu'il passe par cet import
et je suis obligé de contourner et faire
de très longues distances pour pouvoir
donc approcher le pays comme la plupart
des pays africains le Burkina Faso
importe plus de produits qu'il exportent
la crise sécurité a donc des effets
négatifs sur le commerce dans la mesure
où elle réduit considérablement le taux
d'importation pour cette économiste les
autorités burkinabè ont enterré à
redorer l'image du pays pour attirer les
investisseurs
arrive à présenter donc un niveau de
risques modéré ou même faible pour que
les investisseurs puissent avoir
davantage confiance et
rester ok au sein de du pays où
accroître leur activité donc au sein du
pays après le coup d'État de septembre
les États-Unis ont décidé d'exclure le
Burkina Faso de Lagoa qui est une loi de
facilitation des échanges commerciaux
avec les entreprises américaine
un premier contingent de soldats au Mali
pour s'entraîner en Érythrée et rentrer
au pays après des mois de rumeurs sur
leur déploiement secret dans le Tigré la
région en proie à une guerre en Éthiopie
pendant des mois les familles étaient
restées sans nouvelles elles avaient
manifesté pour demander où était leur
proches Caroline lambolie
un soulagement pour les familles mardi
le ministre somalien de la défense a
évoqué le sort des soldats somaliens
envoyés pour s'entraîner en Érythrée
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous faire part
d'une bonne nouvelle qui est importante
pour le peuple somalien et qui constitue
une étape fondamentale dans la lutte
contre alchebabe le premier groupe de
soldats somaliens entraîné en Erythrée
et rentrer en Somalie
les autres seront de retour dans les
prochains jours il rejoindront la lutte
contre alchebab
aucun détail sur leur nombre la présence
de ces soldats en érythrirait reste
entouré de mystères
selon certaines familles leur fils avait
été recruté pour travailler au Qatar
mais il s'était retrouvé en Érythrée où
ils auraient été contraints de servir
dans l'armée certains auraient été
envoyés au combat de l'autre côté de la
frontière dans la région du Tigré en
Éthiopie après des mois de manifestation
et le silence radio de la part de
l'administration précédente le président
nouvellement élu Hassan cher Mohamed
s'est rendu en Érythrée en juillet puis
à nouveau en novembre il y a rencontré
des soldats somaliens et en juillet un
porte-parole rond le silence
5000 soldats étaient portés disparus ils
ont été retrouvés le gouvernement
précédent n'a pas communiqué avec le
peuple au sujet de ce soldats et donc
les gens ont fait circuler des rumeurs
le processus pour leur rapatriement est
en cours le président Somalia a indiqué
l'indique tous les soldats présents en
Érythrée seront rentrés d'ici janvier
les visages en terre cuite des
chibbobgirls ces jeunes filles enlevées
par Boko Haram en 2014 108 d'entre elles
sont toujours en captivité pour lutter
contre l'oubli prune nourri une
plasticienne française c'est inspiré de
sculptures ancestrales Yoruba pour
représenter celles qui sont toujours
entre les mains de leur ravisseur
reportage de notre correspondant au
Nigéria Moïse Gomis
impossible pour ces femmes de contenir
leurs émotions devant ses sculptures
leurs filles compte parmi les ex lycéens
de chibok toujours détenu par Boko Haram
malgré huit ans de souffrance ses mamans
ont accepté que 108 visages de
ichibaugirls soient sculptés pour la
postérité
je suis très heureuse aujourd'hui même
si ce n'est pas maintenant même si cela
va prendre un an ou deux ans ou 10 ans
je reste persuadé que ma fille sera
libre un jour
ne peuvent que nous aider
cette performance l'artiste plasticienne
s'inspire des artisans Yoruba du 15e
siècle elle montre les bons gestes à ses
étudiants nigérian sculptrice
mondialement reconnue prune à mûri ce
projet durant de longues années avant de
collaborer avec l'Université de son
département des Beaux-Arts
collaborés il y a plus d'artisans ici
c'est très très dur à trouver en tout
cas dans la pâte trouver mais
l'université a fait sens et
effectivement on a eu un coup de foudre
pour pour les professeurs ici le
proverbe de département d'art qui sont
incroyables qui ont une philosophie
incroyable c'est 108 têtes de Shibu
girls expriment un message fort contre
la domination masculine et cette
installation était essentielle selon
cette jeune femme Amina Kiki et la
première ex lycéenne de shibok à cette
échappée du sanctuaire de Boko Haram
elle redoute l'indifférence autour du
sort des chipmogles toujours otage
je pense que cette exposition va être
utile pour les filles de chibok encore
en captivité lorsque le monde entier
verra ses sculptures elles seront
heureuses de savoir que les gens parlent
encore d'elle elles ne sont pas
totalement oubliées même si le
gouvernement est resté silencieux alors
sujet depuis un certain temps
pour une nourrir ce silence c'est 108
têtes en terre cuite vont voyager en
Europe en Amérique et en Afrique pour
que les chi bogers ne sombres pas dans
l'oubli
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci aux équipes en régime
merci à notre chef d'édition Celia
carracena merci à notre stagiaire
Raphaël gain Prost merci à nos
correspondants sans qui ce journal ne
pourrait pas se faire et merci à vous
pour votre fidélité je vous retrouve dès
l'année prochaine mais le journal de
l'Afrique continue sur France 24 dès
demain ce sera avec Anthony St Léger et
kalidocious
[Musique]